degreaser levels insufficient for area
cleaning
June lay Tennyson I'm captain around
here but chief to my friends hope you
don't mind the formally
no it isn't it's just so we understand
each other
I'm the final word good
duh so what brings you to Graham
interesting the we see a lot of the same
faces coming
what I didn't think you just Parvati is
it that's a lovely name
what can I do for you I was just
thinking I haven't got much experience
working with actual real spaceships miss
June lay a chief June late June lay is
fine um okay I'd be happy to make the
time Wow great I'll do that then
couldn't have done it with now if
there's nothing
no more fertilizer shipments be brought
on board who keeps ordering me hey
captain can I get you so June Leigh and
I been talk she sent me a poem I don't
know if I should read into it oh la it's
about this engine that's been shaking
itself apart then this I don't want to
get too hopeful but I'm one I don't know
I'm not much interested in it's been a
problem in the pack thanks captain
I actually had another message from June
Leigh I just let's see here they were I
don't know captain I'm feeling all mixed
up right now could we maybe head to the
grip I think
so how's this work
do we get it okay so oh and don't worry
on the prac
oh wow might've have an urgent or an
embarrassing spill wipe it away Oh
captain
I'm panning for June my something fierce
I mean Jeff I don't know what to do
well she talked about another maybe I've
been making a rifle it was real long and
rambly she was this Isabel lady never
quite then it all went down the T
thinking so makes me liable to lose my
luck I need another drink
[Music]
all right here we go
Oh captain
um does she think I'm as pretty as a
what if she soaked there's nothing easy
about you know I'm a that's
of course huh she seems / gosh I don't
know that I got that in me
I suppose so well captain this has been
oh gosh I
okay okay I'm gonna do it thanks for
hearing me out
warning low battery unit is engaging
Reserve huh alright come on
good you're back
nah hey captain I hope I wasn't too much
though that whiskey I message June lay
when we got back and she replied super
quick mmm I reread my message in the
morning and it was unclear I've ruined
things in the past because I want to be
honest with her so she like one of those
two I oughta go write her back
you